[Musik]
mein Name ist Zugsführer Corinna Kuhnle
und wir sind heute hier bei der
Bundesministerin und mich wurde nach
insgesamt 16 Jahren beim
österreichischen Bundesheer hier
verabschiedet
[Musik]
meine Karriere werden nicht möglich
gewesen ohne diese Unterstützung und ich
bin unglaublich dankbar für die Zeit die
ich hier verbringen durfte
[Musik]
hallo ich bin sage ich mal dieses Jahr
ein Gewichtheber jeweils sechs Jahre bei
der osterathischer Bundesheer dabei mein
Ziel ist nach der Karriere als Trainer
weiterarbeiten und die Rechnungen auch
für die Unterstützung bei der
austernative Hunde sehr bedanken weil
ohne die Unterstützung werden die
Medaillen nicht möglich gewesen
danke
[Musik]
mein Name ist Maja Benjamin ich war
jetzt neun Jahre beim österreichischen
Bundesheer als pop-pilot und habe
Österreich auf internationaler Bühne
vertreten
während meiner Zeit beim
österreichischen Bundesheer habe ich
zahlreiche Welt und
europameisterschaftsmedien zusammen mit
meinem Team gewinnen können als auch
mehrere protestplätze im Weltcup diese
ganze Zeit wurde begleitet und
unterstützt vom österreichischen
Bundesheer und in einer Sportart wie
Bobfahren wäre es ohne die Unterstützung
des Bayer einfach nicht möglich gewesen
danke
das Bundesheer und der Leistungssport
das passt gut zusammen und das macht uns
stolz dass er 450 Sportlerinnen und
Sportler auf ihrem Wecker begleiten
dürfen dann ist es aber auch Zeit
Abschied zu nehmen wir dürften heute
drei oder mussten heute drei sehr
verdiente Sportlerinnen Sportler
verabschieden wir wünschen Ihnen alles
erdenklich Gute für ihre weitere Zukunft
sie haben das Bundesheer und Österreich
stolz gemacht
[Musik]